In an age when we are told that
modern-day terrorists have hijacked
Islam.
>> This is what I call a hijacking of
>> There's nothing Islamic about ISIS.
They're hijacking an entire religion.
>> What we see today as, if I could use
President Bush's term, and this is a
term we've all used. Our religion has
been hijacked.
>> And we are not at war with Islam.
We are at war with people who have
perverted Islam. Events that occurred
today in history on a lonely hilltop in
Italy force us to confront a more
uncomfortable truth. Entire sultenates
and caliphates, the most legitimate
expressions of Islamic authority, once
all acted with the same radicalism, the
same theological conviction and the same
blood soaked methods as today's
so-called extremists. Okay, first some
background. When he conquered
Constantinople in 1453, Ottoman Sultan
Muhammad II was only 21 years old with
many decades of conquering still ahead
of him. Now he had heard it prophesied
that quote, "We Muslims will conquer
Constantinople before we conquer Rome."
Not content with being the conqueror of
New Rome, greedy Muhammad was determined
to fulfill the second half of that
prophecy by conquering old Rome as well.
So he spent 27 years terrorizing and
expanding into the Balkans until 1480
when his forces crossed into Italy and
seized the city of Toronto. The sack was
horrific. More than half of the city's
22,000 Christian inhabitants were
massacred and 5,000, the unlucky ones,
mostly women and children, were
enslaved. Then came the Muslims
magnanimous gesture. Freedom was offered
to the remaining male Christian
captives, 813 of them. But first they
were ordered to renounce Christ and
embrace Islam. The Christians responded
in keeping with the exhortation of one
of their numbers. My brothers, one of
the captives had earlier said, we have
fought to save our city. Now it's time
to fight to save our souls. Outraged by
their defiance, on August 14th, all 813
Christians were richly decapitated by
the Muslims at top a barren hill that
would forever after be known as Martyr's
Hill. their families. The now enslaved
women and children were forced to watch
the carnage of their husbands and
fathers as a reminder of the price of
defiance. As for their archbishop, he
was slowly sawn in half to triumphant
cries of Allah Akbar. The bodies and
heads of the Christians were left to rot
at top the hill for over a year until
the Italians managed to liberate and
kick the Muslims out of Toronto. The
skulls of some of these martyrs are
still displayed in the Cathedral of
Toronto, silent witnesses to the horror
of that day. Here is how Giovani Antonio
Sumanti, an Italian contemporary,
described that event. Quote, "When the
city of Atrant was taken by the Ottoman
forces in the year of our Lord, 1480,
the invaders demanded that the
Christians renounce their faith and
convert to Islam, though steadfast in
the Christian confession numbering over
800, refused this demand. As a result,
the Sultan's men led them forth to the
place now called the martyr's chapel,
and there, with cruel hands, executed
them by the sword. Their bodies were
left unburied, a grim testament to their
faith and courage in the face of death.
These brave souls have since been
venerated by the faithful as holy
martyrs who bore witness unto death
rather than deny Christ. Now, keep in
mind, this was not the work of lone
wolves or twisted radicals. It was the
command of the most powerful Muslim
ruler of his age. A man who was a
virtual head of Sunni Islam and who kept
around him a band of muis and other
learned sheh to guide his treatment of
Christian infidels. Surely today's
political refrain that modern-day
jihadist terror is a distortion of
otherwise peaceful Islam collapses in
the face of such a history. The
slaughter at Toronto was Islam as
practiced by its khalif, its jurists and
its armies. Just as today's mass
atrocities and beheadings are Islam as
practiced by ISIS and other terrorist or
organizations and their self-declared
khalifs and scholars, the difference is
one of century, not of creed. Hence why
as American statues and monuments get
toppled all over America, Sultan
Muhammad II remains a hero in modern
Turkey. President Erdogon's conversion
of the Hagya Sophia into a mosque was
partly in homage to this man who was
responsible for the slaughter and
enslavement of possibly millions of
Christians over the course of his
30-year reign. Nor, needless to say, was
a Toronto an isolated atrocity. As
recorded in many Muslim and Christian
chronicles over the centuries, the
leaders and spokesmen of Islam,
sultanss, khalifs, amirs, and shehikhs
of every stripe have repeatedly spoken
and acted like the Islamic State or
rather the Islamic State has modeled
itself on them. The record is consistent
across nearly 14 centuries as documented
in this book, Sword and Scimitar, 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
West. Even more sobering is that then as
now much of the west preferred to deny
rather than confront reality. Pope Sixus
IV appalled at Western Europe's
indifference soon after a Toronto warned
in a letter that quote let them not
think that they are protected against
invasion those who are at a distance
from the theater of war. He meant about
Western Europe. The Turks have sworn the
extinction of Christianity a truce to
sophistries. It is the moment not to
talk but to act and fight. This was an
old lament. Decades earlier, before
Constantinople's fall, Cardinal Julian
had chastised Christendom's indifference
in very similar tone. Look all around
you and see how the people of Christ are
trotten upon and devoured by Turks,
Sarris, and Tartars, Muslims, all. Why
do you not commiserate with the many
thousands of your brothers who year
after year are reduced to the harsh
servitude of the infidel? But what is
more pitiful is that many of those who
are led into captivity and who are not
able to bear such a hard servitude deny
the Christian faith and are led to the
abhorrent sect of Muhammad, meaning they
convert to Islam. How many kingdoms,
provinces, cities, towns are daily
seized and depopulated. They have now
cornered you in a small area in the
west. Discord among Christians is the
cause of all these calamities. If they
would only grow wise and harbor love,
this sort of persecution would soon end.
But the west remained in a stuper. Some
85 years after Otranto in 1565, as the
Ottomans prepared their massive siege of
Malta, Pope Pius IV complained that the
king of Spain has quote withdrawn into
the woods and France, England, and
Scotland are ruled by women and boys.
That said, and like now, a few did see
the pattern clear enough. Sebastian
Brandt's Ship of Fools, a poem from
1494, lamented how Christendom had lost
the strongholds it once held throughout
the Middle East to Islam. He wrote,
quote, "Our faith was strong in the
Orient, but now we perish, sleeping one
and all. The wolf has come into the
stall and steals the holy church's
sheep. The while the shepherd lies
asleep. Four sisters of our church you
find Constantinople, Alexandria,
Jerusalem, Antioch. But they've been
forfeited and sacked and soon the head
Rome will be attacked. To learned
Europeans, the Ottoman threat was simply
the latest wave in a relentless tide. As
one clergyman put it, quote, "The Arabs
were the first troops of locusts. The
Turks, a brood of vipers, are worse than
their parent, the Sarissens, their
mother." In short, the names always
change. Omayads, Abbassad, Ottoman,
Al-Qaeda, Boo Haram, Islamic State, but
the creed and the methods remain the
same. Each is a fresh brood of vipers
hatched from the same nest, carrying
forward the same jihad. The martyrs of
Toronto are a reminder that the past is
never really passed, and that the
supposed gulf between the Islam of the
caliphates and the Islam of modern-day
terrorists is an illusion we impose on
ourselves.
[Music]